không ngay 1 bún tằng ba năm 2021 vụ một thay quân phối hợp với các địa phương tiếp diện câu dân nhà bún năm 2018
lấy ra những quân đả sức xác trang trọng, nghiên gọi đúng kydik bào đam an toàn.
2021 vụ một thay quân tiếp diện hơn một nghìn trình sĩ mới từ thêm phố hại phòng và các tình còn niệm
hơn íên, mi bình, tình hoả, bây gửi nưởng tảy lữa đoạn một bún mì và tự đoạn 1 năm tám vụ một thay quân.
Hoàn thành một trong phần trăm chỉ tiếp cấp trình dọc.
Để bảo đam rất lượng tuyên quan, chỉ viết các đơn vị đã trụ động phối hợp chả trẻ với cấp y,
chính quyền địa phương trường hay đầy đủ các khâu, các mức trong khi chính tiền trọn công dân như bố thật đủ như địa
thực hiện công thay, mình bài đúng lột bảo đam ăn toàn từ đối.
Như đó, rất lượng tuyên địa nè như bố năm nay được đánh giá cao, có su khai tốt, chính độ vinh hóa phù hợp, sớ sản bố bảo mua chiếng quân lúc.
Tại lẽ ra hiện quân ở các địa phương, thu trường bộ tư lượng vùng đã chức tiếp và bớt, lộn viên, các giản các chiến xí mới phát viên trên tổ quay gương cách mạng tinh cần xung kích của tủ trên.
Tí cơ khọt tập, dẹn lựa cho thành nghiên kỳ lợt, xây dựa bản lính chính chi vấn vòng phòng phòng chất đạo đức trong sáng,
sớt sản hiện bỏ hàn thành tốt mọi nhẹ vụ được sảo.
Các đơn vị hỗ lượng chính xí mới đã trụ động phối hợp với đơn vị kích nghĩa trên địa bàn vào hội phụ nước phòng chính chi vòng một tổ trức trả đó,
tạo ra chút mừng, chục anh lưu liệp tạo không khi phân khởi ở mắt tiếp theo đồng lực để chiến xí mới ít tâm công tác, quyết tâm hàn thành tốt nghiệp vụ ngày từ những ngày đầu hiếp vụ.